hi I'm Jerry halwell horer and I'm here
with BuzzFeed to answer 30 questions as
quickly as
possible I had eggs for
breakfast British Bake Off I love
sugar none of
them I prefer just being at home in my
jeans Adventure power finding the
courage you never knew you had that
wasn't three words
your song John or board line
Madonna Oscar wild Shakespeare CS
Lewis The Book
Thief there
is depends Emma
probably no Talent is
useless I just like
cake no I think I know what I need to
know about myself would you want to play
you in the movie of your life Wow wow
okay Florence Pew Emma Stone to name a
few there's so
many I would go for an unknown Lindsay
Lohan kind of vibe or Drew barimore when
they were
younger I'm just a
Scorpio there's none really I love
Aquarian as
well I just sent a text for whoopy
Goldberg I love her oh my
God
can't you can never say never but I
don't know I like writing music I'd like
singing but whether I do a whole album
I'm not
sure can't do that doesn't belong to me
it belongs to
everyone if you can't
dance I am on Tik Tok I do have
Instagram and you see a lot of
animals okay the Roman Empire is very
interesting it was the age of stoicism M
you know the philosophy have a look
Marcus Aurelius it's good I wouldn't say
in the Forefront of my mind but you know
I think we can all learn from the past
definitely I mean there's so many
amazing leaders out there go for Queen
Elizabeth the first she was amazing can
you imagine she had to rule an Empire
herself and she was 25 years old so much
peer pressure of men and she did it so
amazingly she was a falcon Queen and her
mother got her head chopped
off
oh probably more than once a week it's
it's a few times a
day wow there are so many place I love
America I love the optimism when I come
to New York it feels like a film set so
I do like New York I absolutely love
Austin I love Texas I just
think you've got such good
maners I'm not really visiting m i but I
do love London I think it's brilliant
it's got so much culture and it's a
Melting Pot of cultures it's wonderful
I'm very proud of
that it's such a team sport there is a
particular team principal that I think
is
incredible I've just read tomorrow
tomorrow and tomorrow that's really good
it made me cry it's brilliant and
surprising I was sort of didn't want it
to end good
writing Brave big heart big shoes
Brave still big shoes big
heart Oh either a teacher or president
can you your eyes yeah I mean I spice is
gorgeous she's lovely and she's
red um maybe have a
toast I don't know say thank
you I did bye BuzzFeed and Rosie Frost
and the Falcon Queen my new novel is out
now check it
[Music]
out